The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN TSITSIKLIS: And we're going
to continue today with
our discussion of classical
statistics.
We'll start with a quick review
of what we discussed
last time, and then talk about
two topics that cover a lot of
statistics that are happening
in the real world.
So two basic methods.
One is the method of linear
regression, and the other one
is the basic methods and
tools for how to
do hypothesis testing.
OK, so these two are topics
that any scientifically
literate person should
know something about.
So we're going to introduce
the basic ideas
and concepts involved.
So in classical statistics we
basically have essentially a
family of possible models
about the world.
So the world is the random
variable that we observe, and
we have a model for it, but
actually not just one model,
several candidate models.
And each candidate model
corresponds to a different
value of a parameter theta
that we do not know.
So in contrast to Bayesian
statistics, this theta is
assumed to be a constant
that we do not know.
It is not modeled as a random
variable, there's no
probabilities associated
with theta.
We only have probabilities
about the X's.
So in this context what is a
reasonable way of choosing a
value for the parameter?
One general approach is the
maximum likelihood approach,
which chooses the
theta for which
this quantity is largest.
So what does that mean
intuitively?
I'm trying to find the value of
theta under which the data
that I observe are most likely
to have occurred.
So is the thinking is
essentially as follows.
Let's say I have to choose
between two choices of theta.
Under this theta the
X that I observed
would be very unlikely.
Under that theta the X that I
observed would have a decent
probability of occurring.
So I chose the latter as
my estimate of theta.
It's interesting to do the
comparison with the Bayesian
approach which we did discuss
last time, in the Bayesian
approach we also maximize over
theta, but we maximize a
quantity in which the relation
between X's and thetas run the
opposite way.
Here in the Bayesian world,
Theta is a random variable.
So it has a distribution.
Once we observe the data, it has
a posterior distribution,
and we find the value of Theta,
which is most likely
under the posterior
distribution.
As we discussed last time when
you do this maximization now
the posterior distribution is
given by this expression.
The denominator doesn't matter,
and if you were to
take a prior, which is flat--
that is a constant independent
of Theta, then that
term would go away.
And syntactically,
at least, the two
approaches look the same.
So syntactically, or formally,
maximum likelihood estimation
is the same as Bayesian
estimation in which you assume
a prior which is flat, so that
all possible values of Theta
are equally likely.
Philosophically, however,
they're very different things.
Here I'm picking the most
likely value of Theta.
Here I'm picking the value of
Theta under which the observed
data would have been more
likely to occur.
So maximum likelihood estimation
is a general
purpose method, so it's applied
all over the place in
many, many different types
of estimation problems.
There is a special kind of
estimation problem in which
you may forget about maximum
likelihood estimation, and
come up with an estimate in
a straightforward way.
And this is the case where
you're trying to estimate the
mean of the distribution of X,
where X is a random variable.
You observe several independent
identically
distributed random variables
X1 up to Xn.
All of them have the same
distribution as this X.
So they have a common mean.
We do not know the mean we
want to estimate it.
What is more natural than just
taking the average of the
values that we have observed?
So you generate lots of X's,
take the average of them, and
you expect that this is going to
be a reasonable estimate of
the true mean of that
random variable.
And indeed we know from the weak
law of large numbers that
this estimate converges in
probability to the true mean
of the random variable.
The other thing that we talked
about last time is that
besides giving a point estimate
we may want to also
give an interval that tells us
something about where we might
believe theta to lie.
And 1-alpha confidence interval
is in interval
generated based on the data.
So it's an interval from this
value to that value.
These values are written with
capital letters because
they're random, because they
depend on the data
that we have seen.
And this gives us an interval,
and we would like this
interval to have the property
that theta is inside that
interval with high
probability.
So typically we would take
1-alpha to be a quantity such
as 95% for example.
In which case we have a 95%
confidence interval.
As we discussed last time it's
important to have the right
interpretation of what's
95% means.
What it does not mean
is the following--
the unknown value has 95%
percent probability of being
in the interval that
we have generated.
That's because the unknown
value is not a random
variable, it's a constant.
Once we generate the interval
either it's inside or it's
outside, but there's no
probabilities involved.
Rather the probabilities are
to be interpreted over the
random interval itself.
What a statement like this
says is that if I have a
procedure for generating 95%
confidence intervals, then
whenever I use that procedure
I'm going to get a random
interval, and it's going to
have 95% probability of
capturing the true
value of theta.
So most of the time when I use
this particular procedure for
generating confidence intervals
the true theta will
happen to lie inside that
confidence interval with
probability 95%.
So the randomness in this
statement is with respect to
my confidence interval, it's
not with respect to theta,
because theta is not random.
How does one construct
confidence intervals?
There's various ways of going
about it, but in the case
where we're dealing with the
estimation of the mean of a
random variable doing this is
straightforward using the
central limit theorem.
Basically we take our estimated
mean, that's the
sample mean, and we take a
symmetric interval to the left
and to the right of
the sample mean.
And we choose the width of that
interval by looking at
the normal tables.
So if this quantity, 1-alpha is
95% percent, we're going to
look at the 97.5 percentile of
the normal distribution.
Find the constant number that
corresponds to that value from
the normal tables, and construct
the confidence
intervals according
to this formula.
So that gives you a pretty
mechanical way of going about
constructing confidence
intervals when you're
estimating the sample mean.
So constructing confidence
intervals in this way involves
an approximation.
The approximation is the
central limit theorem.
We are pretending that
the sample mean is a
normal random variable.
Which is, more or less,
right when n is large.
That's what the central limit
theorem tells us.
And sometimes we may need to
do some extra approximation
work, because quite often
we do not know the
true value of sigma.
So we need to do some work
either to estimate
sigma from the data.
So sigma is, of course, the
standard deviation of the X's.
We may want to estimate it from
the data, or we may have
an upper bound on sigma, and we
just use that upper bound.
So now let's move on
to a new topic.
A lot of statistics in the
real world are of the
following flavor.
So suppose that X is the SAT
score of a student in high
school, and Y is the MIT GPA
of that same student.
So you expect that there is a
relation between these two.
So you go and collect data for
different students, and you
record for a typical student
this would be their SAT score,
that could be their MIT GPA.
And you plot all this data
on an (X,Y) diagram.
Now it's reasonable to believe
that there is some systematic
relation between the two.
So people who had higher SAT
scores in high school may have
higher GPA in college.
Well that may or may
not be true.
You want to construct a model of
this kind, and see to what
extent a relation of
this type is true.
So you might hypothesize that
the real world is described by
a model of this kind.
That there is a linear relation
between the SAT
score, and the college GPA.
So it's a linear relation with
some parameters, theta0 and
theta1 that we do not know.
So we assume a linear relation
for the data, and depending on
the choices of theta0 and theta1
it could be a different
line through those data.
Now we would like to find the
best model of this kind to
explain the data.
Of course there's going
to be some randomness.
So in general it's going to be
impossible to find a line that
goes through all of
the data points.
So let's try to find the best
line that comes closest to
explaining those data.
And here's how we go about it.
Suppose we try some particular
values of theta0 and theta1.
These give us a certain line.
Given that line, we can
make predictions.
For a student who had this x,
the model that we have would
predict that y would
be this value.
The actual y is something else,
and so this quantity is
the error that our model would
make in predicting the y of
that particular student.
We would like to choose a line
for which the predictions are
as good as possible.
And what do we mean by
as good as possible?
As our criteria we're going
to take the following.
We are going to look at the
prediction error that our
model makes for each
particular student.
Take the square of that, and
then add them up over all of
our data points.
So what we're looking at is
the sum of this quantity
squared, that quantity squared,
that quantity
squared, and so on.
We add all of these squares, and
we would like to find the
line for which the sum of
these squared prediction
errors are as small
as possible.
So that's the procedure.
We have our data, the
X's and the Y's.
And we're going to find theta's
the best model of this
type, the best possible model,
by minimizing this sum of
squared errors.
So that's a method that one
could pull out of the hat and
say OK, that's how I'm going
to build my model.
And it sounds pretty
reasonable.
And it sounds pretty reasonable
even if you don't
know anything about
probability.
But does it have some
probabilistic justification?
It turns out that yes, you can
motivate this method with
probabilistic considerations
under certain assumptions.
So let's make a probabilistic
model that's going to lead us
to these particular way of
estimating the parameters.
So here's a probabilistic
model.
I pick a student who had
a specific SAT score.
And that could be done at
random, but also could be done
in a systematic way.
That is, I pick a student who
had an SAT of 600, a student
of 610 all the way to 1,400
or 1,600, whatever the
right number is.
I pick all those students.
And I assume that for a student
of this kind there's a
true model that tells me that
their GPA is going to be a
random variable, which is
something predicted by their
SAT score plus some randomness,
some random noise.
And I model that random noise
by independent normal random
variables with 0 mean and
a certain variance.
So this is a specific
probabilistic model, and now I
can think about doing maximum
likelihood estimation for this
particular model.
So to do maximum likelihood
estimation here I need to
write down the likelihood of the
y's that I have observed.
What's the likelihood of the
y's that I have observed?
Well, a particular w has a
likelihood of the form e to
the minus w squared over
(2 sigma-squared).
That's the likelihood
of a particular w.
The probability, or the
likelihood of observing a
particular value of y, that's
the same as the likelihood
that w takes a value of y
minus this, minus that.
So the likelihood of the
y's is of this form.
Think of this as just being
the w_i-squared.
So this is the density --
and if we have multiple data you
multiply the likelihoods
of the different y's.
So you have to write something
like this.
Since the w's are independent
that means that the y's are
also independent.
The likelihood of a y vector
is the product of the
likelihoods of the
individual y's.
The likelihood of every
individual y is of this form.
Where w is y_i minus these
two quantities.
So this is the form that the
likelihood function is going
to take under this
particular model.
And under the maximum likelihood
methodology we want
to maximize this quantity with
respect to theta0 and theta1.
Now to do this maximization you
might as well consider the
logarithm and maximize the
logarithm, which is just the
exponent up here.
Maximizing this exponent because
we have a minus sign
is the same as minimizing
the exponent
without the minus sign.
Sigma squared is a constant.
So what you end up doing is
minimizing this quantity here,
which is the same as
what we had in our
linear regression methods.
So in conclusion you might
choose to do linear regression
in this particular way,
just because it looks
reasonable or plausible.
Or you might interpret what
you're doing as maximum
likelihood estimation, in which
you assume a model of
this kind where the noise
terms are normal random
variables with the same
distribution --
independent identically
distributed.
So linear regression implicitly
makes an assumption
of this kind.
It's doing maximum likelihood
estimation as if the world was
really described by a model of
this form, and with the W's
being random variables.
So this gives us at least some
justification that this
particular approach to fitting
lines to data is not so
arbitrary, but it has
a sound footing.
OK so then once you accept this
formulation as being a
reasonable one what's
the next step?
The next step is to see how to
carry out this minimization.
This is not a very difficult
minimization to do.
The way it's done is by setting
the derivatives of
this expression to 0.
Now because this is a quadratic
function of theta0
and theta1--
when you take the derivatives
with respect
to theta0 and theta1--
you get linear functions
of theta0 and theta1.
And you end up solving a system
of linear equations in
theta0 and theta1.
And it turns out that there's
very nice and simple formulas
for the optimal estimates
of the parameters in
terms of the data.
And the formulas
are these ones.
I said that these are nice
and simple formulas.
Let's see why.
How can we interpret them?
So suppose that the world is
described by a model of this
kind, where the X's and Y's
are random variables.
And where W is a noise term
that's independent of X. So
we're assuming that a linear
model is indeed true, but not
exactly true.
There's always some noise
associated with any particular
data point that we obtain.
So if a model of this kind is
true, and the W's have 0 mean
then we have that the expected
value of Y would be theta0
plus theta1 expected value of
X. And because W has 0 mean
there's no extra term.
So in particular, theta0 would
be equal to expected value of
Y minus theta1 expected
value of X.
So let's use this equation
to try to come up with a
reasonable estimate of theta0.
I do not know the expected
value of Y, but I
can estimate it.
How do I estimate it?
I look at the average of all the
y's that I have obtained.
so I replace this, I estimate
it with the average of the
data I have seen.
Here, similarly with the X's.
I might not know the expected
value of X's, but I have data
points for the x's.
I look at the average of all my
data points, I come up with
an estimate of this
expectation.
Now I don't know what theta1 is,
but my procedure is going
to generate an estimate of
theta1 called theta1 hat.
And once I have this estimate,
then a reasonable person would
estimate theta0 in this
particular way.
So that's how my estimate
of theta0 is going to be
constructed.
It's this formula here.
We have not yet addressed the
harder question, which is how
to estimate theta1 in
the first place.
So to estimate theta0 I assumed
that I already had an
estimate for a theta1.
OK, the right formula for the
estimate of theta1 happens to
be this one.
It looks messy, but let's
try to interpret it.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to take this model for
simplicity let's assume that
they're the random variables
have 0 means.
And see how we might estimate
how we might
try to estimate theta1.
Let's multiply both sides of
this equation by X. So we get
Y times X equals theta0 plus
theta0 times X plus theta1
times X-squared, plus X times
W. And now take expectations
of both sides.
If I have 0 mean random
variables the expected value
of Y times X is just the
covariance of X with Y.
I have assumed that my random
variables have 0 means, so the
expectation of this is 0.
This one is going to be the
variance of X, so I have
theta1 times variance of X. And
since I'm assuming that my
random variables have 0 mean,
and I'm also assuming that W
is independent of X this last
term also has 0 mean.
So under such a probabilistic
model this equation is true.
If we knew the variance and the
covariance then we would
know the value of theta1.
But we only have data, we do
not necessarily know the
variance and the covariance,
but we can estimate it.
What's a reasonable estimate
of the variance?
The reasonable estimate of the
variance is this quantity here
divided by n, and the reasonable
estimate of the
covariance is that numerator
divided by n.
So this is my estimate
of the mean.
I'm looking at the squared
distances from the mean, and I
average them over lots
and lots of data.
This is the most reasonable way
of estimating the variance
of our distribution.
And similarly the expected value
of this quantity is the
covariance of X with Y, and then
we have lots and lots of
data points.
This quantity here is going to
be a very good estimate of the
covariance.
So basically what this
formula does is--
one way of thinking about it--
is that it starts from this
relation which is true
exactly, but estimates the
covariance and the variance on
the basis of the data, and then
using these estimates to
come up with an estimate
of theta1.
So this gives us a probabilistic
interpretation
of the formulas that we have for
the way that the estimates
are constructed.
If you're willing to assume that
this is the true model of
the world, the structure of the
true model of the world,
except that you do not
know means and
covariances, and variances.
Then this is a natural way of
estimating those unknown
parameters.
All right, so we have a
closed-form formula, we can
apply it whenever
we have data.
Now linear regression is a
subject on which there are
whole courses, and whole
books that are given.
And the reason for that is that
there's a lot more that
you can bring into the topic,
and many ways that you can
elaborate on the simple solution
that we got for the
case of two parameters and only
two random variables.
So let me give you a little bit
of flavor of what are the
topics that come up when you
start looking into linear
regression in more depth.
So in our discussions so far
we made the linear model in
which we're trying to explain
the values of one variable in
terms of the values of
another variable.
We're trying to explain GPAs
in terms of SAT scores, or
we're trying to predict GPAs
in terms of SAT scores.
But maybe your GPA is affected
by several factors.
For example maybe your GPA is
affected by your SAT score,
also the income of your family,
the years of education
of your grandmother, and many
other factors like that.
So you might write down a model
in which I believe that
GPA has a relation, which is a
linear function of all these
other variables that
I mentioned.
So perhaps you have a theory of
what determines performance
at college, and you want to
build a model of that type.
How do we go about
in this case?
Well, again we collect
the data points.
We look at the i-th student,
who has a college GPA.
We record their SAT score,
their family income, and
grandmother's years
of education.
So this is one data point that
is for one particular student.
We postulate the model
of this form.
For the i-th student this would
be the mistake that our
model makes if we have chosen
specific values for those
parameters.
And then we go and choose the
parameters that are going to
give us, again, the
smallest possible
sum of squared errors.
So philosophically it's exactly
the same as what we
were discussing before, except
that now we're including
multiple explanatory variables
in our model instead of a
single explanatory variable.
So that's the formulation.
What do you do next?
Well, to do this minimization
you're going to take
derivatives once you have your
data, you have a function of
these three parameters.
You take the derivative with
respect to the parameter, set
the derivative equal
to 0, you get the
system of linear equations.
You throw that system of
linear equations to the
computer, and you get numerical
values for the
optimal parameters.
There are no nice closed-form
formulas of the type that we
had in the previous slide
when you're dealing
with multiple variables.
Unless you're willing to go
into matrix notation.
In that case you can again
write down closed-form
formulas, but they will be a
little less intuitive than
what we had before.
But the moral of the story is
that numerically this is a
procedure that's very easy.
It's a problem, an optimization
problem that the
computer can solve for you.
And it can solve it for
you very quickly.
Because all that it involves
is solving a
system of linear equations.
Now when you choose your
explanatory variables you may
have some choices.
One person may think that your
GPA a has something to do with
your SAT score.
Some other person may think that
your GPA has something to
do with the square of
your SAT score.
And that other person may
want to try to build a
model of this kind.
Now when would you want
to do this? ?
Suppose that the data that
you have looks like this.
If the data looks like this then
you might be tempted to
say well a linear model does
not look right, but maybe a
quadratic model will give me
a better fit for the data.
So if you want to fit a
quadratic model to the data
then what you do is you take
X-squared as your explanatory
variable instead of X, and you
build a model of this kind.
There's nothing really different
in models of this
kind compared to models
of that kind.
They are still linear models
because we have theta's
showing up in a linear
fashion.
What you take as your
explanatory variables, whether
it's X, whether it's X-squared,
or whether it's
some other function
that you chose.
Some general function h of X,
doesn't make a difference.
So think of you h of X as being
your new X. So you can
formulate the problem exactly
the same way, except that
instead of using X's you
choose h of X's.
So it's basically a question
do I want to build a model
that explains Y's based on the
values of X, or do I want to
build a model that explains Y's
on the basis of the values
of h of X. Which is the
right value to use?
And with this picture here,
we see that it can make a
difference.
A linear model in X might be
a poor fit, but a quadratic
model might give us
a better fit.
So this brings to the topic of
how to choose your functions h
of X if you're dealing with
a real world problem.
So in a real world problem
you're just given X's and Y's.
And you have the freedom
of building models of
any kind you want.
You have the freedom of choosing
a function h of X of
any type that you want.
So this turns out to be a quite
difficult and tricky topic.
Because you may be tempted
to overdo it.
For example, I got my 10 data
points, and I could say OK,
I'm going to choose an h of X.
I'm going to choose h of X and
actually multiple h's of X
to do a multiple linear
regression in which I'm going to
build a model that's uses a
10th degree polynomial.
If I choose to fit my data with
a 10th degree polynomial
I'm going to fit my data
perfectly, but I may obtain a
model is does something like
this, and goes through all my
data points.
So I can make my prediction
errors extremely small if I
use lots of parameters, and
if I choose my h functions
appropriately.
But clearly this would
be garbage.
If you get those data points,
and you say here's my model
that explains them.
That has a polynomial going up
and down, then you're probably
doing something wrong.
So choosing how complicated
those functions,
the h's, should be.
And how many explanatory
variables to use is a very
delicate and deep topic on which
there's deep theory that
tells you what you should do,
and what you shouldn't do.
But the main thing that one
should avoid doing is having
too many parameters in
your model when you
have too few data.
So if you only have 10 data
points, you shouldn't have 10
free parameters.
With 10 free parameters you will
be able to fit your data
perfectly, but you wouldn't be
able to really rely on the
results that you are seeing.
OK, now in practice, when people
run linear regressions
they do not just give
point estimates for
the parameters theta.
But similar to what we did for
the case of estimating the
mean of a random variable you
might want to give confidence
intervals that sort of tell you
how much randomness there
is when you estimate each one of
the particular parameters.
There are formulas for building
confidence intervals
for the estimates
of the theta's.
We're not going to look
at them, it would
take too much time.
Also you might want to estimate
the variance in the
noise that you have
in your model.
That is if you are pretending
that your true model is of the
kind we were discussing before,
namely Y equals theta1
times X plus W, and W has a
variance sigma squared.
You might want to estimate this,
because it tells you
something about the model, and
this is called standard error.
It puts a limit on how
good predictions
your model can make.
Even if you have the correct
theta0 and theta1, and
somebody tells you X you can
make a prediction about Y, but
that prediction will
not be accurate.
Because there's this additional
randomness.
And if that additional
randomness is big, then your
predictions will also have a
substantial error in them.
There's another quantity that
gets reported usually.
This is part of the computer
output that you get when you
use a statistical package which
is called R-square.
And its a measure of the
explanatory power of the model
that you have built
linear regression.
Using linear regression.
Instead of defining R-square
exactly, let me give you a
sort of analogous quantity
that's involved.
After you do your linear
regression you can look at the
following quantity.
You look at the variance of Y,
which is something that you
can estimate from data.
This is how much randomness
there is in Y. And compare it
with the randomness that you
have in Y, but conditioned on
X. So this quantity tells
me if I knew X how much
randomness would there
still be in my Y?
So if I know X, I have more
information, so Y is more
constrained.
There's less randomness in Y.
This is the randomness in Y if
I don't know anything about X.
So naturally this quantity would
be less than 1, and if
this quantity is small it would
mean that whenever I
know X then Y is very
well known.
Which essentially tells me that
knowing x allows me to
make very good predictions about
Y. Knowing X means that
I'm explaining away most
of the randomness in Y.
So if you read a statistical
study that uses linear
regression you might encounter
statements of the form 60% of
a student's GPA is explained
by the family income.
If you read the statements of
this kind it's really refers
to quantities of this kind.
Out of the total variance in Y,
how much variance is left
after we build our model?
So if only 40% of the variance
of Y is left after we build
our model, that means that
X explains 60% of the
variations in Y's.
So the idea is that
randomness in Y is
caused by multiple sources.
Our explanatory variable
and random noise.
And we ask the question what
percentage of the total
randomness in Y is explained by
variations in the X parameter?
And how much of the total
randomness in Y is attributed
just to random effects?
So if you have a model that
explains most of the variation
in Y then you can think that
you have a good model that
tells you something useful
about the real world.
Now there's lots of things that
can go wrong when you use
linear regression, and there's
many pitfalls.
One pitfall happens when you
have this situation that's
called heteroskedacisity.
So suppose your data
are of this kind.
So what's happening here?
You seem to have a linear model,
but when X is small you
have a very good model.
So this means that W has a small
variance when X is here.
On the other hand, when X is
there you have a lot of
randomness.
This would be a situation
in which the W's are not
identically distributed, but
the variance of the W's, of
the noise, has something
to do with the X's.
So with different regions of our
x-space we have different
amounts of noise.
What will go wrong in
this situation?
Since we're trying to minimize
sum of squared errors, we're
really paying attention
to the biggest errors.
Which will mean that we are
going to pay attention to
these data points, because
that's where the big errors
are going to be.
So the linear regression
formulas will end up building
a model based on these data,
which are the most noisy ones.
Instead of those data that are
nicely stacked in order.
Clearly that's not to the
right thing to do.
So you need to change something,
and use the fact
that the variance of W changes
with the X's, and there are
ways of dealing with it.
It's something that one needs
to be careful about.
Another possibility of getting
into trouble is if you're
using multiple explanatory
variables that are very
closely related to each other.
So for example, suppose that I
tried to predict your GPA by
looking at your SAT the first
time that you took it plus
your SAT the second time that
you took your SATs.
I'm assuming that almost
everyone takes the
SAT more than once.
So suppose that you had
a model of this kind.
Well, SAT on your first try and
SAT on your second try are
very likely to be
fairly close.
And you could think of coming
up with estimates in which
this is ignored.
And you build a model based on
this, or an alternative model
in which this term is ignored,
and you make predictions based
on the second SAT.
And both models are likely to be
essentially as good as the
other one, because these
two quantities are
essentially the same.
So in that case, your theta's
that you estimate are going to
be very sensitive to little
details of the data.
You change your data, you have
your data, and your data tell
you that this coefficient
is big and that
coefficient is small.
You change your data just a
tiny bit, and your theta's
would drastically change.
So this is a case in which you
have multiple explanatory
variables, but they're redundant
in the sense that
they're very closely related
to each other, and perhaps
with a linear relation.
So one must be careful about the
situation, and do special
tests to make sure that
this doesn't happen.
Finally the biggest and most
common blunder is that you run
your linear regression, you
get your linear model, and
then you say oh, OK.
Y is caused by X according to
this particular formula.
Well, all that we did was to
identify a linear relation
between X and Y. This doesn't
tell us anything.
Whether it's Y that causes X, or
whether it's X that causes
Y, or maybe both X and Y are
caused by some other variable
that we didn't think about.
So building a good linear model
that has small errors
does not tell us anything about
causal relations between
the two variables.
It only tells us that there's
a close association between
the two variables.
If you know one you can make
predictions about the other.
But it doesn't tell you anything
about the underlying
physics, that there's some
physical mechanism that
introduces the relation between
those variables.
OK, that's it about
linear regression.
Let us start the next topic,
which is hypothesis testing.
And we're going to continue
with it next time.
So here, instead of trying
to estimate continuous
parameters, we have two
alternative hypotheses about
the distribution of the
X random variable.
So for example our random
variable could be either
distributed according to this
distribution, under H0, or it
might be distributed according
to this distribution under H1.
And we want to make a decision
which distribution is the
correct one?
So we're given those two
distributions, and some common
terminologies that one of them
is the null hypothesis--
sort of the default hypothesis,
and we have some
alternative hypotheses--
and we want to check whether
this one is true,
or that one is true.
So you obtain a data
point, and you
want to make a decision.
In this picture what would
a reasonable person
do to make a decision?
They would probably choose a
certain threshold, Xi, and
decide that H1 is true if your
data falls in this interval.
And decide that H0 is true
if you fall on the side.
So that would be a
reasonable way of
approaching the problem.
More generally you take the set
of all possible X's, and
you divide the set of possible
X's into two regions.
One is the rejection region,
in which you decide H1,
or you reject H0.
And the complement of that
region is where you decide H0.
So this is the x-space
of your data.
In this example here, x
was one-dimensional.
But in general X is going to
be a vector, where all the
possible data vectors that
you can get, they're
divided into two types.
If it falls in this set you'd
make one decision.
If it falls in that set, you
make the other decision.
OK, so how would you
characterize the performance
of the particular way of
making a decision?
Suppose I chose my threshold.
I may make mistakes of
two possible types.
Perhaps H0 is true, but my data
happens to fall here.
In which case I make a mistake,
and this would be a
false rejection of H0.
If my data falls here
I reject H0.
I decide H1.
Whereas H0 was true.
The probability of
this happening?
Let's call it alpha.
But there's another kind of
error that can be made.
Suppose that H1 was true, but by
accident my data happens to
falls on that side.
Then I'm going to make
an error again.
I'm going to decide H0 even
though H1 was true.
How likely is this to occur?
This would be the area under
this curve here.
And that's the other type of
error than can be made, and
beta is the probability of this
particular type of error.
Both of these are errors.
Alpha is the probability
of error of one kind.
Beta is the probability of an
error of the other kind.
You would like the
probabilities
of error to be small.
So you would like to
make both alpha and
beta as small as possible.
Unfortunately that's not
possible, there's a trade-off.
If I go to my threshold it this
way, then alpha become
smaller, but beta
becomes bigger.
So there's a trade-off.
If I make my rejection region
smaller one kind of error is
less likely, but the
other kind of error
becomes more likely.
So we got this trade-off.
So what do we do about it?
How do we move systematically?
How do we come up with
rejection regions?
Well, what the theory basically
tells you is it
tells you how you should
create those regions.
But it doesn't tell
you exactly how.
It tells you the general
shape of those regions.
For example here, the theory
who tells us that the right
thing to do would be to put
the threshold and make
decisions one way to the right,
one way to the left.
But it might not necessarily
tell us
where to put the threshold.
Still, it's useful enough to
know that the way to make a
good decision would
be in terms of
a particular threshold.
Let me make this
more specific.
We can take our inspiration
from the solution of the
hypothesis testing problem
that we had in
the Bayesian case.
In the Bayesian case we just
pick the hypothesis which is
more likely given the data.
The produced posterior
probabilities using Bayesian
rule, they're written
this way.
And this term is the
same as that term.
They cancel out, then let me
collect terms here and there.
I get an expression here.
I think the version you
have in your handout
is the correct one.
The one on the slide was
not the correct one, so
I'm fixing it here.
OK, so this is the form of how
you make decisions in the
Bayesian case.
What you do in the Bayesian
case, you
calculate this ratio.
Let's call it the likelihood
ratio.
And compare that ratio
to a threshold.
And the threshold that you
should be using in the
Bayesian case has something
to do with the prior
probabilities of the
two hypotheses.
In the non-Bayesian case we do
not have prior probabilities,
so we do not know how to
set this threshold.
But we're going to do is we're
going to keep this particular
structure anyway, and maybe use
some other considerations
to pick the threshold.
So we're going to use a
likelihood ratio test, that's
how it's called in which we
calculate a quantity of this
kind that we call the
likelihood, and compare it
with a threshold.
So what's the interpretation
of this likelihood?
We ask--
the X's that I have observed,
how likely were they to occur
if H1 was true?
And how likely were they to
occur if H0 was true?
This ratio could be big if my
data are plausible they might
occur under H1.
But they're very implausible,
extremely unlikely
to occur under H0.
Then my thinking would be well
the data that I saw are
extremely unlikely to have
occurred under H0.
So H0 is probably not true.
I'm going to go for
H1 and choose H1.
So when this ratio is big it
tells us that the data that
we're seeing are better
explained if we assume H1 to
be true rather than
H0 to be true.
So I calculate this quantity,
compare it with a threshold,
and that's how I make
my decision.
So in this particular picture,
for example the way it would
go would be the likelihood ratio
in this picture goes
monotonically with my X. So
comparing the likelihood ratio
to the threshold would be the
same as comparing my x to the
threshold, and we've got
the question of how
to choose the threshold.
The way that the threshold is
chosen is usually done by
fixing one of the two
probabilities of error.
That is, I say, that I want my
error of one particular type
to be a given number,
so I fix this alpha.
And then I try to find where
my threshold should be.
So that this probability theta,
probability out there,
is just equal to alpha.
And then the other probability
of error, beta, will be
whatever it turns out to be.
So somebody picks alpha
ahead of time.
Based on the probability of
a false rejection based on
alpha, I find where my threshold
is going to be.
I choose my threshold, and that
determines subsequently
the value of beta.
So we're going to continue with
this story next time, and
we'll stop here.